sitting here Chris and rich Robinson who
started the Black Crowes hold hands guys
I feel terribly uncomfortable and
whenever I see anybody feel anything I'm
like he was just seen drinking salsa
straight from the can I wasn't drinking
I was eating it this is kind of crazy to
me because uh well let me just say who's
sitting here sitting together for the
first time and I don't know how many
years hold hands guys
oh must be killing anybody disinfectant
sitting here are the two founding
members the guys who started all Chris
and rich Robinson who started the Black
Crowes many many years ago you are in
the same room and you're here today to
announce what Chris we're announcing
that the Black Crowes are together and
that we're going on tour next next
summer we're playing the Bowery Ballroom
tonight how did this wow this is a
miracle I don't care what you tell me
this is a he's saying it like he doesn't
believe rich first of all this is a
miracle how does this happen that you
and Chris you guys I love your band
I love the Black Crowes and and rich
isn't it something of a miracle when two
guys born into a family actually can
write and perform music together I mean
to me it's a billion to one shot am I
right or am I wrong I think you're right
yeah you know I think ultimately we
share a similar experience
you know from two different perspectives
obviously it's an amazing story to me
because there are very few brothers and
at the way I look at you two guys you
filled in each other's kind of missing
parts rich you can play the guitar Chris
you had no interest in playing guitar
but Chris was the singer Chris could
come up with lyrics and you could come
up with these fabulous riffs and this
music what are the [ __ ] odds of you
know what's one thing that Keith
Richards found Mick Jagger but they
weren't born into the same family
same shop it's legendary that the
Robinson brothers as great as you guys
are together you could never really be
in the same room Chris I had you on two
years ago no no I said he said some
shitty thing said some horrible thing
you said some bad thing I was in a
negative place but you know you know
what I've apologized to rich about that
how did this come about that you two
guys even started talking you hadn't
talked in what four years she said I
know thanks years six years I no longer
have her brother he doesn't exist you
can't stand each other you don't want to
be in a room together and here you are
sitting in my studio I just found my you
know and I mean a lot of things have
changed for me in the last two years you
know I was in a relationship that was
failing I was in a negative place you
make some big changes in your life I
mean I found I mean I have an amazing
partner amazing you have a new
girlfriend new girlfriend everything
good there it's been going on for a
couple years it's incredible who has
this idea that we could actually get
along and be in a band together again we
have a we have a friend that that we
that is in between us and does it well
his name's Greg I thought it was dr.
Phil know who picked up the phone and
called well we both did
right interestingly at different times
like right but right around the same
time and and and you know look I was
going out playing you know songs you
know in my new band and playing crow
songs cuz a lot of the guys from the
crows are in my band and and no matter
what it is there's that half of me that
was missing right and and so in that
same sense although it was great to play
with those guys and those guys are
brilliant and it was cool and fun but
there's it's almost like the more I
don't delved into that the more it was
obvious there was a glaring omission
which was my brother Gary
Gary's telling me that somehow I don't
know how he got into this but he's
having a vinyl party at Rachael Ray's
house well she said he keeps threatening
Gary what's up are you gonna do that now
are you personal Prince oh I'm friends
with with their executive producer and
also a little friendly with her husband
so I invited the executive producer you
know I said we're going to try to put
something together so we're you going to
do it
I said we haven't figured it out yet he
called me back a couple days later he
said they'd like to host it so what is a
vinyl party again for those of us who
don't know it'll just be a bunch of
people who like vinyl and then bring and
everyone will bring a record and then we
have a theme of the pool have a theme
for the party which has a bit chosen yet
jukebox songs my way Frank Sinatra have
you ever been over Rachael Ray's
apartment as well but why do you need to
sit in a room with Fred Armisen is
really more like a community experience
than a listening experience it's not
like we're going for four high-fidelity
you talk while the music is going
there's a crackle coming up what do you
will kind of see me you're thinking
about it Rachel's house how about Desert
Island Discs what do you mean a cooking
of food thing Lily the fellated song
food yeah like love ray no me what would
be a food song yummy yummy yummy I got
love in my tummy would that qualify yeah
I guess that would American Pie bag on
the cleaners did witness the last time
you went to a vinyl party and what was
it where was the theme it might have
been one with cities and didn't you
bring Chuck Berry the b-side Havana Mon
that's correct
[Music]
something even Chuck Berry doesn't want
to hear Chuck Berry who is embarrassed
by that will be there I think like John
heiner joining me and there's a couple
people work on the staff that would like
to go where to Rachel Ray's apartment
damn right I like to see what's doing
play the entire breakfast in America by
Supertramp because it's a scene how
about these are people that were in
before they knew where it was gonna be
how about hey good-looking
well you got cooking something up with
me
yeah jambalaya jambalaya hanka Williams
yeah that's food for more on this topic
let's go to our phone Rob and Gary
audiobook ah hi Gary
how you doing this is Gary yeah what's
up I love being that guy when it comes
to music knowledge right here here I
used all the money I earned mowing lawns
and delivering newspapers to buy records
I even used my mowing money to buy Rock
n Roll trivia books a plastic sleeves
for all my album what is it all my 45s
on a shelf in my room right next to my
bed in alphabetical order what is it
about alphabetizing albums and and being
that guy and what is that guy yeah right
here all right thanks he likes being I
don't know what that guy is before the
internet people would often call me for
to ask questions about music that's okay
Gary puppet are you that guy I'm that
guy right lady mama loud yeah
voulez-vous coucher avec moi ce soir
real Gary does everyone high-five when a
really cool song comes on or no
everybody is talking right and then what
if somebody's the next person's turn out
clean man's coming on Shh
little spiel about why they picked the
song and in the song plays and then
everybody's continues to drink and talk
and then the next person comes out
alright alright I'm gonna kill myself
alright thanks yeah now ladies and
gentlemen the great
JD name-o
area for those who have never heard the
great Jay Dini you will get a glimpse
into the future of our world what will
happen yes it's 2019 oh but we wanted to
know what will happen the years ahead
oh great one Oh Krusty she'd clairvoyant
please in your infinite wisdom tell us
what our futures will be what great
things will happen my mumbling mystic
and please say them as articulately and
clearly as humanly possible I know it's
difficult oh great why yes oh hey JD
Tucker I'm a floating head with cheeto
dust in my head
I speak an ancient mumbly language
called hanging you don't already you'll
be quiet and let me get through this Oh
giggly mumbly crystal gazer you who
wears glasses but sees way into the
future you who says hmm
like almost a grunting animal Oh my
Mushmouth Merlyn it is time jdd oh great
one the medium who wears an extra-large
are you ready to speak yes are you ready
for my first prediction I really am I
predict Rani the limo drivers fiancee
will burst into tears at her wedding
what she realizes Rani lived through the
entire ceremony oh great one oh my pudgy
profits
oh my smelly shaman what is your next
prediction I predict the LGBTQIA pee
will start calling themselves the drama
club to save time a real Nostradamus
predictor of things that will come what
else will our future hold please oh
great Jay Dini
I predict that instead of finding coal
this year naughty kids open their
stockings to find jet season tickets it
was all right in other words what you
were saying is the kids are gonna find
instead of coal in their stocking
Jesse's nutty goes when he said nutty
kids all right
oh my reader of tea leaves and waster of
income enlighten us oh great one Oh what
is your next prediction
I predict an earthquake will strike
Mexico that is so powerful the country
splits open and candy falls out like a
pinata
oh great bomber of comedy there isn't a
joke that I can't kill you got a CJD
knees in a a green-screen
outfit which means it's a tight green
leotard your part like so on the end you
could see his head floating I say [ __ ]
the effect just show me
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm afraid
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so don't renege on water to the truth
there God
tell your baby my older cook
you might acting crazy you're not just
too proud
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
did you go to Fenway Park and throw out
the first pitch right over the plate and
Varitek car and it didn't touch the dirt
and it was from the mound proper proper
for you you for six months to practice
for that when you see Papa flow highs
that was really you you practice you
practiced for three months six six
months six months I had a pitch back in
my driveway and then I went to hey nurse
barn and actually add a pitching coach
for the last couple weeks because you
didn't want to embarrass yourself and I
wanted to throw it was very important
for me as a woman to throw from the
mound right I got a PG like full full
distance were you shocked by the lack of
finesse that pop up phooey himself had I
mean here's a guy claims he was a coach
for Little League and all this always
mean one is do you laugh at a guy like
this did you know I feel terribly
uncomfortable and super embarrassed
whenever I see anybody feel anything I'm
like do you imagine the shame I felt
when my producers just missed completely
and through it like Gary be teaching
kids to pitch or is that something that
he should not be doing in your opinion
he should be inspiring them then she
didn't wear a coat to work here we go
he's wearing a t-shirt Benjy aren't you
cold no when I was a kid I did think it
looked like cool I thought it was like
really uncool to wear coat or okay but
now this is the true answer I would love
to get a winter coat I have trouble
deciding which coat to buy they see that
sounds silly to me it's not a joke and
it can't go to a store so your coat
you'll I can buy it's because I'm I want
to get the perfect one and that's with a
lot of things in my life there's no no
no I agree that that is a all right okay
thank you didn't I give you a coat last
year and I wearing what happened to that
um it was a beautiful coat and it just
there was another guy that works with us
that that
it fit better and I gave it to him all
right thanks did you ever get a wallet
or used to walk around that plastic bag
full of money I had a problem with the
plastic bag I go to a 12-step meeting
you would have a dress that means for
eating a free Overeaters Anonymous and
uh it's so supportive it's a good how's
that going to you losing weight so I was
in a meeting and someone's like what
they pass a bag to collect money for
rent for the room put it in like two or
three dollars and someone goes where's
the bag and I just didn't really pay
attention to somebody so they said it
again like the treasurer where's the bag
then also my god I pocketed the bag by
mistake
because it's a plastic bag I got
confused I thought it was my wallet but
I had to pull out I was like look I have
two bags I'm really sorry
right and they laughed they believe me
but so I did start after that I started
using a couple years ago Wendy got me a
wallet and I started using that one all
right
fascinating he confused his plastic bag
with the bag they were passing well
Thank You Betsy fascinating you put what
I do wrong nothing that be in other
words I we just wanted to hear if you
had a wallet and I heard it now I'm done
yeah that's it
now go outside and freeze what is it
Jason I have a weird Benjy update go
ahead he was just seen right before he
came in here drinking salsa straight
from the can well very straight from the
bottle why would you do that how the
ovaries anonymous has to tell you that
that's not good for you in terms of
calories even no no that was just
because I had salsa and I was just but
why would you drink that straight though
it's not even good I wasn't drinking it
I was eating it all right thanks thanks
for whatever your name is Jason Wow he's
a guy going over he's anonymous he's
shrinking out about salsa kebab
you guys look at like I'm thinking of
the guys from Oasis those two brothers
they can't [ __ ] get in the room
either do you look at them and go are
they ridiculous
they should just get together it's not I
completely we toured with them that must
have been and we freaked them out they
couldn't believe how much you guys
fought when you guys would get into
physical fights there were rules right
you couldn't hit each other in the face
that was the one rule pretty much would
you kick him in the shin the elbow in
the throat no face look Howard you know
when you have these kind of good looks
[ __ ] it up another thing we had to take
our music seriously because we just
didn't want to coast on the good looks
you know and you can't break your
brother's fingers because he's got to
play the guitar and you can't keep you
in the throat cuz you got to sing but we
really wanted to hurt each other so
you're saying when you were on tour with
Oasis they freaked out Oh your fights
were so loud and vicious that they were
like jeez
we got to be we got a really big fight
and at Merriweather Post Oh Chris was
late to soundcheck and everyone was
freaking out and so he and I got into
and our tour manager walked outside and
Liam and Noah were outside the door
going boy they need help I mean like Don
and Phil Everly they didn't like each
other okay and Dave Davies they had
issues legendary but brothers but I kind
of get it I mean it's just the way you
know brothers it's hard in families to
get along really I wouldn't change
anything in really yeah rich you would
you wouldn't want to go through that
again with the angst teaches you you
know a lot of times the it's the harder
things in life that really are the ones
that have the lesson well you got a
[ __ ] man up a little bit Oh Howard
the pain was unbelievable so up the
charts
Bobo recently bit his fingernail down
too far so it got infected a doctor had
to poke his finger with a needle and
drain it Shirley was on the phone with
Bobo while the procedure was happening
and recorded Bobo's reaction and Bobo it
couldn't have been that painful
step inspection how it went in my hand
up to my arm
here's Bobo at the doctor's office I was
washing my hands and [ __ ] listen to
this the overacting is ridiculous
[Music]
sounds like Bobo's [ __ ] his back to
clean they don't give you anything Alex
you're like a little kid they should
give me a lollipop after you got drained
Julie talked to Bobo later that day Bobo
said he did something stupid after the
treatment but wouldn't say what it was
truely pressed him on it Bobo finally
admitted he had recorded a goodbye
message to everyone in his life because
he felt he was going to die from his
finger infection I just got back from
the doctor's office I'm in a tremendous
amount of pain due to an infection in my
finger the throbbing at the hand it's
going up my hand in my arm I just feel
like it's gonna go to my heart and kill
me I just feel this might be my last
goodbyes you know when you get to this
plateau on life you know you don't know
what's gonna happen Plateau you know
this could be the end I just got a shot
in my ass to help subside the pain and I
have in my finger a needle up yes
bubble puppet on the one hand you say
they gave you nothing and then you say
there was a needle in your ass
whoops I screwed up I have wok disease
that's where your whole body starts
turning into a rock and it starts with
your brain chemical I'm on trauma call
yeah I need trauma talk from this phone
call all right thank you
hey I got to tell you that this is not a
commercial but our sponsor Klondike bar
and it says Reese's on it I guess they
teamed up on Robbie just for that one is
that a peanut butter thing - why do they
call it caramel pretzel if it's peanut
butter Gary goes Breezies peanut butter
cups
wheezy's that you didn't hear - Reese's
I thought it was some weird way that
they pronounced it for a profit
I know it's Reese's no you don't you
only say these you even said that when
we had et in that movie and we did it's
racist you've always said reason I'm not
I will
you always say reezy hundred bucks
you're onyx I've heard him say Reese's a
million times I've heard you say it even
in your personal life I know it's
Reese's yeah your favorite cartoon was
Baba looey and you said Baba Booey and
your favorite candy is Reese's and you
said reesy I think he's thinking Reese's
monkey rhesus monkey dude everyone in
here was laughing at you yeah I'll go
I'll go searching through our archives
because I need the 500 bucks yeah what
why would Baba looey be Baba Booey
no one in one is - and I'm telling you
twice here you dopey these bowls Reese's
bowl [ __ ] I want Weezy
[Applause]
claim Samri ZZZ
why can repeat any idiotic thing you
know your breath smells like feces both
your lazy's clown dagmar easy species
Bulls yes Ralph you know it is Gary
loves to talk so much he doesn't look
like think before he talks he just blurt
stuff out like please ease now you don't
know you don't know me
Roscoe he's there I know you I love you
but again Lisa Jake I just yelled at
least a teach comes in my office she
goes what happened was you you combine
Reese's and pcs that's not what [ __ ]
happened no you said Reese's before you
said it to me in private
absolutely positive I'm sure you're
wrong heard you say we you see you're
looking for an angle on something but
it's not there I've never said it I've
heard you swearing a life my kids and I
know you can't prove it cuz it just
never happened my favorite telling you
I've heard you you know you just made us
a business you should time now you say
Reese's you just make [ __ ] up because it
helps move the baby is saying you don't
you have that tape because somebody
effect I'm almost like them why would
you say because I thought that maybe
they called it a different you don't
mean in other words it's one of those
goofy names that klondike made up like
I've heard you say before that's a lie
no you really have it I really have no
the funny thing is you really give me a
lie detector I've heard you really
haven't heard me say it before but now
you can't turn back cause you look full
no III will turn I will apologize to you
if I'm wrong but I'm not really have it
I've heard you say Reese's you have not
you've said it a million times I have
not in fact we did a show once where we
put Reese's Pieces on the floor and I
remember you saying to me both will
cease be seized first well I don't
remember that show I did and and it's
it's just not Alyssa I don't mind you
have selective memory but you have
selective memory
I guess I'm wrong okay every dollar is
Reese's bababooey what's your favorite
cartoon character Bugs Bunny no we know
it's Baba looey Baba Booey and you swore
you you call it Babu there's no time
there's no doubt that that we're out and
you thought it was Reese's I know it's
not Reese's it's okay it's just you know
all right forget it
why [ __ ] with your bit right all right
okay thanks care oh good you can leave
now
[Laughter]
[Music]
she keeps a lock of hair in her pocket
she wears a cross around her neck
[Music]
turn across from someone she had that
there
[Music]
[Music]
the
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
canopy's everything
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well she picks her ass of blackheads a
night
[Music]
cheaper back down tight said my girl
won't give a little smile with a bang
come
the pain the only thing to make it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't know what to say that is
fantastic
look at you guys oh man that is exciting
bye for now
the Howard Stern Show